here we go and three
two one action
and background action
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
three two one action
very nice
[Music]
[Music]
uh
that makes sense
[Music]
[Music]
this unpredictable
[Music]
[Music]
yet
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i loved creating the stunt sequences in
this film the action is
explosive
this is an action movie but it's also
beautiful to look at
the film consists of a lot of fight
sequences there's a lot of
training and rehearsal involved
they were tremendously hard working is
extremely exciting
i've had three months of training
process
it's quite challenging six or seven
hours
a day it's been really helpful yeah i
feel like i can do more push-ups
she's the best warrior amongst us
we get specific for the actors getting
them up to speed from basic handling of
weapons
all the way through to rolling falling
running jumping that sort of stuff
[Music]
we're doing a lot of stunt fighting
sword training i feel like i'm training
with like the best of the best
i've never ever had a six-pack in my
life i'm starting to see some come
through so it's really really exciting
we had physical army style training we
also had stunts and martial arts
horseback riding archery military
marching you name it
all of the cast were brilliant and they
trained hard it's not just
action for action sake it's all coming
from character
and from story every action is very
meaningful
fire the stunt sequences
are epic you've never seen anything
quite so extraordinary in your life
we'll protect each other we'll fight for
each other
she's everything an action movie hero
should be particularly when picking us
with his sword
it is my duty to vote in order to bring
this legendary story to life i had a
huge vision for the live-action mulan
the film needed to be massive
because this is an epic action adventure
movie
nikki understands the chinese culture
and she loves mulan
so she will bring to the world a very
special hugo
and she also likes a big kick-ass movie
and that's what she's making
the way that nikki wanted to shoot the
stunts was
not in a rough and rugged way but to be
elegant and beautiful
nikki sees the action through different
eyes
she's really in tune with character
development
and how we use the action to drive the
story
this story is epic and emotional
ancestors please protect her that
emotional connection to her actors
is nikki's forte nikki will push to
the fine details of what she's looking
for
and take it to a very real place nikki
is
an actress director she's really about
the performance
and that's what's most precious on
screen
it's such an honor and a tremendous
responsibility
to bring mulan to life in a new way
the world of mulan is so rich the
costumes
the colors the real landscapes and we've
assembled the most extraordinary cast of
this movie
led by lou yi faye nobody else could
have played the role of mulan
she's a brilliant actress but that was
only one part of the equation
we put her through a grueling physical
assessment
she's an accomplished martial artist
every moment
yifei was on set she raised the bar and
she inspired all of us
one of my favorite moments was shooting
donnie yen's
martial arts skills as commander tong he
does a sword display
in front of all of the recruits the way
he
moves a sword it moves so fast i had to
shoot the sequence again
in slow motion just so i could see what
he was doing he is astonishing
this is a big vision of a big journey
and i'm so happy that we've been able to
deliver
an epic vision of mulan's story
i will bring honor to us all been a
physical actor in
action films and stuff but never
training to this degree
this version of milan bori khan is our
villain
he's played by jason scott lee and he
has resurrected
an army that is so powerful he intends
to take the kingdom
korikan's joined by a witch shenyang
played by gong lee
you will die pretending to be something
you're not
the stunt choreography and design is
incredible in this movie
we wanted to do something very different
the sword work and the stunt work i
think all those elements combined the
preparation of it all
really helped me develop who or khan was
destroyed
the witch is a human weapon she's able
to shapeshift
into many things but most often the hawk
her costume has walk details her weapons
are on her body
the witch has supernatural element to
her so a lot of wire work involved which
sort of blends in to create her overall
style
i could tear you to pieces before you
blink
it does feel epic and it does feel
bigger than life
you really get a sense that these
characters are from a different world
this movie's very real
and very visceral as an action movie
should be
it's going to be a wild ride
it's
[Music]
okay thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
okay
to eraser good thought